what's going on reject nation we're
going to watch some film theory today
matpat back at it how wonder woman
doomed
humanity wonder woman 1984. i went on a
hike
just got back i had to be wearing my
wonder woman shirt so i was like
this is a sign this is a sign to cover
film theory's
latest video let's do this
[Music]
you know sometimes it feels like as soon
as i make a prediction theory the
studios re-edit the movies just to spite
me
like the time i called raya palpatine
and then episode eight was like no
no she's not she's a nobody and then
there are those other times
i'm 100 absolutely sure that nobody in
hollywood's listening to me and today is
one of those days
but hey that's just uh
here let's let's talk about wonder woman
[Music]
i feel like you're almost 100 right
about your batman one
hello internet battlefield film theory
the show that's now doing sequels to its
own theories dedicated fans may remember
back in 2017
when i ran a theory that wonder woman
would never have made it from themseyra
to london in time for
the end of world war one the tldr of
that theory was basically that her boat
was too slow and the available waterways
to get her there weren't help in the
situation the link is in the upper right
hand corner of the screen in case you
missed that one i personally like that
episode
a whole heck of a lot anyway at the time
i thought zack snyder was to blame for
the shoddy math but i guess now it's
time to apologize
i'm sorry zach don't get me wrong it's
not because the math makes any more
sense now than it did back then
still doesn't just a huge turd sandwich
of job on the map in that one but the
reason i'm sure
for sure had nothing to do with the
newest dc movie wonder woman 1984
and wouldn't you know it there's still
another major math issue with the travel
in this new film which gotta say it's
time
considering the whole theme of the movie
is not cheating to get ahead and well
they cheated the math to you know get
ahead you cheated
and truth is all there is now because
the movie's new and not everybody has
access to hbo max gonna try to minimize
the spoilers i'm not gonna talk about
the end of the movie or any major
twists but here's your minor spoiler
warning for the first third of the film
in a scene that's been featured in every
trailer wonder woman and steve trevor
get into a fighter jet in dc and fly it
non-stop to cairo egypt i'm here to tell
you that in this movie full of
massive massive plots this is probably
the biggest diana and steve would have
probably died in a fiery ball of death
before ever finishing the trip the truth
is what powers it not me
the truth is bigger than all of us well
i'm glad you feel that way diana cause
your movie certainly disagrees so let's
set the scene here
okay let's hear this but now brought
back to life boyfriend steve are hunting
down an ancient artifact known as the
dreamstone
which has the ability to grant wishes
kind of
[Music]
admittedly the mechanism of this thing
is a bit inconsistent probably a theory
for another day anyway
[Laughter]
a failing oil baron named maxwell lord
max is on a trip to cairo egypt to
secure
huge oil reserves from one of the most
oil rich men in the world since steve
trevor
technically died back in 1918 he doesn't
have himself a valid passport so they
can't just hop on a commercial flight so
how do you get to egypt you steal
an airplane you cheated diana no that's
not cheating that's
just borrowing from another
resourcefulness for an indeterminate
amount of time now this theory isn't
about stupid plot holes and it's
important to remember that a character
not thinking of something doesn't count
as a plot hole but before we move
forward i just gotta say it they bring
steve back to life by having him be in
another man's body
like he is one dude and he says hey i'm
steve at a party and diana doesn't
recognize him but then a minute later
she starts seeing him as steve but to
the rest of the world he's still this
other guy
it's creepy it has disturbing
implications about stephen diana's
relationship
with the movie but ignoring all of that
possessed dude
probably had himself a valid passport
just saying you could have saved
yourself some trouble just by checking
anyway they walk right into what we're
told is the smithsonian archives and
steal one of the fighter jets on exhibit
taking off for a romantic flight using
the airstrip that is somehow right
outside
unlikely that that's really where they
are in reality i think they're instead
at the stephen f
udvar-hazy center just outside of
washington which
is a smithsonian affiliated museum with
direct access to dulles international
airport
but i just wanted to call it out so
steve a foreign is amazed that modern
planes can fly so far
how is this so far you have a plane that
can fly from here to cairo in one shot
and of course there are plenty of planes
that can make it that far the distance
from dulles airport to cairo egypt
is 5822 miles or 9369 kilometers and the
longest regularly scheduled flight in
the world is singapore airlines's direct
flight from singapore to newark new
jersey
or fifteen thousand three forty three
kilometers uncomfortable
eight hour 5822 miles
may not be close to the longest flight
on earth but it's still
a very long flight and most planes
aren't made for anything
nearly that long and there's one key
reason why
it should surprise them
fuel is heavy and the more fuel you have
on board the fewer passengers cargo and
other things you can carry
this means that all planes are made with
a trade-off never thought of fuel
of course fighter jets only have one or
two passengers and their cargo is mostly
munitions but fighter jets are also made
to be highly maneuverable the more fuel
you have stored in your wings the more
you have to worry about your ability to
make sharp maneuvers and the more
[Music]
is a modified raf pnavia tornado it's a
british
plane but there's a major issue with
that the seating arrangement you see the
tornado seats pilots in tandem one pilot
forward and the second one behind not
the side-by-side seating arrangement
that we see in the movie
many fighter jets choose to do this
because it's a more aerodynamic
arrangement requiring less frontal
area from a design standpoint it's much
easier to stretch the nose of the plane
out a bit to add a second position
rather than making the whole thing wider
because of the manufacturing aerodynamic
issues side-by-side seating and fighter
jets is actually a fairly rare thing
one of the few models that featured it
the soviets were bigger fans of the
side-by-side seating arrangement than
most for instance their su-24 would have
had side-by-side seating that looks a
lot more like the cockpit shots from
wonder woman in reality the plane that
we see in the movie
russian trainers russian tampering with
the film
decently bigger but it turns out none of
this really matters because none of
those planes are making it anywhere
close to cairo remember the trip from
dallas to cairo is 5822 miles
9369 kilometers so how do these titans
of air superiority stack up
terribly because fighter aircraft have
different ranges depending on whether
they're going into battle or cruising
there are usually two different ranges
associated with each type of craft
the combat range which is the range of
the plane when it's loaded for combat
and the ferry range which is the range
of the aircraft when it's carrying it's
loaded for ferry
it's pretty surprising to me that the
smithsonian would just keep a plane
around with a full tank of gas just in
case someone has to
kill it and tried to fly to egypt but
let's look like they're loaded with live
ammo so i'm going to be going
off of the ferry range assuming the
plane of the panavia tornado that we see
in the exterior shots the ferry range
is hundred 2 fifty miles four thousand
two sixty four kilometers
not even half the difference it needs to
make it to cairo the su-24 does
way worse with a ferry range of one
thousand seven hundred and twenty-four
miles
four kilometers and the f-111 can do a
bit better at 3690 miles
i thought there were no more plot holes
to uncover
all of them and again jesus
that means not only will these planes
not make it to cairo they're not even
making it to africa
even if we wanted to write these in
their favor diana and steve
are doomed the closest point in america
one of those boats that's where you'd
expect it's not down in florida where
you might think but
way up on the quadi head peninsula of
maine
yeah maine is the closest state to
africa wrap your head around that one
this point is 3 154 miles away from
africa
barely within the best best case
scenarios range the f-111
with maximum extra fuel tanks they're
not even going to come close to making
landfall
diana and steve are doomed
invisible i love this sound remember the
reported max ranges of these games
are optimized
as well as well-trained pilots that's
your second problem
steve is not a well-trained pilot
sure he was probably one of the best
pilots of world war one but in 1984
aviation has made some major advances
really inspiring some confidence in your
abilities there bud in world war 1
50 hours of training and had an average
life expectancy of
69 flight hours after that that means
that steve trevor probably had around
100 to 120 hours of flight experience at
most and had only ever flown
in non-pressurized propeller driven
aircraft the fact that steve could
figure out a modern jet enough to get it
off the ground is a miracle but making
the plane fly
optimally is a whole nother issue steve
is
not making for a great pilot here and we
know that because the first thing he
does is
fly through fireworks
[Laughter]
it's actually more efficient for a plane
to fly at higher altitudes it's because
the air gets thinner as you get higher
which actually grants two outputs to the
plane
first and probably the one you've
already guessed there's less air
resistance in front of the plane
meaning that it can push forward with
less effort the second benefit comes
from the way air and fuel combine to
create combustion
in an engine fuel is always flowing into
chambers being compressed by pistons and
exploding the size of that explosion
depends highly on how much air is also
in the chamber when the explosion
happens
at higher altitudes where the air is
thinner you actually need a higher
volume of that thinner air to create the
optimal explosion to drive the engine
airplanes have the ability to change the
mixture of air and fuel at will to
create optimized engine output the
higher you go
the leaner you can make your mixture
which can save up to 25
on total gas usage wow so much thought
goes into fly
it's not that
or 12 easy feet before they stopped
working so he'd probably consider
that high altitude travel above 12 500
feet today the faa requires pilots to
have oxygen on board so even if a plane
in world war one could have made it
above that altitude the pilots would be
passing out to pressurized cockpits this
is going to be far below the optimal
altitude for any modern jet
even the highest altitude aircraft of
world war one
german bombers reached at absolute most
24
000 feet better but still far below
optimal cruising altitudes for long
distances i really love the way these
are ready david
don't have a chance of making it but you
know what forget all of this
throw away the flight ranges the plane
types steve's lack of flying experience
none of it matters even if they had a
plane that could go the distance and a
pilot with experience to get them there
there's one thing they can't avoid
getting shot out of the air
fight your gift i'll never understand it
that's not the only thing you don't
understand diana but i understand how
radar works
kind of a big deal so when steve and
diana hit the runway with the purloined
plane
alarms start going off the control
towers notified that hey
some unidentified aircraft is on the
runway and about to take off don't worry
steve's an ace pilot that's going to
outrun him
the way i fly they will never find us oh
wait
it's the 80s now there's been a new
innovation in the world of flight
tracking
called radar radar i can't explain that
with lcs anywhere
even in the dark to escape detection at
the last minute diana uses her
incredibly ill-defined power
set to you know turn the jet invisible
it's a fun nod to the old wonder woman
comics and tv show where the
but it probably wouldn't work and sure
you could
use a magical cloaking ability to hand
wave away the authorities tracking you
down and shooting your plane out of the
sky
it's all magic why should radar work on
a magical plane
well that excuse would have worked
except they made one key mistake
they flew through fireworks see the
movie shows us the invisible plane
as it flies through fireworks and clouds
carving its
shape
specifically for things
that radar sends out radio waves which
then bounce off of a physical object and
go back to the receiver
telling that receiver that hey there is
an object there we've covered all this
before in the past sonic the hedgehog
movie theory
that was the basics of radar and that
alone would show that an object able to
push clouds and fireworks out of the way
i was literally going like but they
turned
invisible one step further because when
it comes to control
it's radio waves there is an added
wrinkle once your plane takes off your
pilot activates a transponder device
inside the aircraft the transponder
detects incoming radar signals and
broadcasts an encoded radio signal back
with flight number
altitude air speed destination
information like that a blip
representing the airplane wasn't patty
jenkins
his dad a pilot yes i believe
he was he was not consulted
the fact that the control tower saw the
plane on its radar means that it was on
and wouldn't just go away because the
plane is no longer visible
sure diana might know more about 80s
culture than steve
but she certainly doesn't seem to know
any more about 80s scientific
advancements
any way you slice this one that rogue
aircraft is going to be shot down out of
the sky
long before it gets anywhere close to
africa for the
second time in as many movies wonder
woman has failed us because of a basic
transportation related miscalculation in
the last movie
modern jet fighters would result in both
of them plummeting into the middle of
the atlantic ocean
the theme of the movie was to not cheat
to get ahead but you know maybe the
theme should have been
do your research before you try and
cheat for dc
or any of the writers of these movies
please if anyone is over there listening
please
please think about this next time so far
my two wonder woman theories have all
been about transportation
[Laughter]
so funny oh jesus
theory and you should consider
subscribing to see when one
does for sure because it was just
confirmed what horrific miscalculation
we're gonna expose in that one
subscribe button is right below this
video it's bright and red
and happy for a bright red start to 2021
help this channel
cross the 10 million subscribers how is
it not a 10 million
play button and you know what 50 million
weekly content delivered to your time
anything less is unacceptable wonder
wonderful
like wonder woman wonderful like wonder
woman all right i'm done
guys if you haven't subscribed to film
theory what are you doing
these are magical what are you doing do
it guys
do it i love the experience of this one
specifically because my mind just
started going off of
so many things i think like a lot of us
we probably walked into here going okay
all right
we've heard a lot about plot holes with
wonder woman 1984.
the video is called how wonder woman
doomed us is that was that the exact
title is called
i want to redo humanity so i'm like all
right there's probably going to be
some crazy thing about the magic or some
choice that she made
yeah it's going to deal with that and
should you do is get this entire
gigantic breakdown of just this
plane moment the plane moment's been
criticized constantly
right and we've been part of that camp
too like how did they just get away with
that did they ever return the plane
was the guy whoever steve trevor was
posing as was he hunted down by the fbi
afterwards for stealing the plane a
whole bunch of things how did he learn
how did he know how to fly the plane it
doesn't make any sense and then a lot of
people go you guys are just nitpicking
the vibe that i got from this video
which was making me laugh
so much i felt like someone told matt
and then like
phil theory has like several writers but
i felt like someone told matt pat
you're nitpicking and then he got like
super defensive
and it was like let me show you how this
is not nitpicking exactly
all of this does not work at all this is
nonsense
sometimes i you know you walk into film
theory like the one i i
i mentioned during this was the batman
one uh with robert pattinson
you listen to those you're like man i
actually could see that being the actual
plot and what the twist might be
for that batman movie i walked into here
thinking a similar thing i just love the
self-awareness too like i love to talk
about the lore one of these things
yeah i can't get past some of these very
obvious things to hit to him and the
team's mind
technicalities of things in the real
world that would not apply
so i just i had a i had just a hoot
watching this
is so freaking fun like yes well
detailed well constructed well thought
out
wonderfully edited the whole concept of
it for mckinnon just became so
funny to me well yeah and plus it's just
a great like
physics aeronautics and engineering
breakdown
digest for anybody who doesn't know much
about that side of science because i was
sitting here like getting engrossed and
forgetting like
oh yeah this is about how wonder woman
doomed humanity which is i guess with a
fiery plane crash miscalculated
terribly this flight it's funny to me
that talking about not wanting to
nitpick leads to like
the pick but then when you hear it
unpacked
it is so like legitimate in a way
because it is just like the physics of
actual technology in
actual earth so i feel like those things
are kind of fair to harp on especially
like i want one wonder no pun intended i
know there was a lot of push and pull
behind the scenes that movie that's
top coming out uh and i wonder how patty
jenkins
felt about some of these plain things
because you brought up like
i was a pilot and she's gotta know
something about this well you know i
mean i think even if her
okay just because her dad is a pilot
wouldn't mean that she
is an expert right i get that my mom is
the manager of an insurance company and
i know barely anything about insurance
all right so i can't act like just
because your dad is but i feel like she
would at least
have the resources and know the right
people to talk to when trying to figure
this stuff out i didn't even think about
majority of this
this stuff i didn't even bother to
really question could the plane make it
that wasn't really one of my main
concerns i'm like movies get away with
crap
like doing travel and distance all the
time so like something i didn't even
bother to to question
like i loved just how the more detail he
went he just kept explaining how
not one piece of this works
not one piece not one piece of it like
even at the end
when they go let's scrap all that let's
just say
forget all that let's say you had all
the maximum fuel
let's say you had all this all this all
this all this the moment that a lot of
people did love
was the fireworks moment and then it
brings up how
that immediately would have gotten them
detected on the radar
and how when the film itself beyond the
photo it gave up before they got to the
fireworks how like when they're zipping
through the clouds
it's bringing the outline of life oh
damn
that's so true even the magical moment
about like oh but
that's what makes it i just love that
it's so funny
yeah and i mean you know in the moment i
guess you could chalk it up to magic but
the thought had crossed my mind like
making the jet invisible is not just
gonna automatically make sounds not
bounce off
because that's how radar works and yeah
like at the time i was just
flying through fireworks seemed like a
risky idea just because what if one of
them hits you but yeah i never thought
it would
i never thought of that aspect of making
it that much more obvious and pointing
out your location and stuff
again nitpicking except when they start
to like
pile up like this it starts to suggest
that maybe you just don't have a
well-constructed scene
i thought we have uncovered from
everything we've thought about from the
questions and everything you guys have
posed
all the countless videos i've seen on
wonder woman 1984. and i must
have heard everything about this there
will be more
people will scour this movie and find
other things
this was one this was so freaking
hilarious hilarious in all the different
kinds of ways it's not just funny
because of the jokes just the entire
thing is funny
because it's just what it's so focused
on
it's like it's funny but it's also
engrossing because you're like learning
stuff and they're like great because
editing is great like it's a
perfect little package so yeah i do
gotta say like thank you to the film
theory team for putting this together
and uh guys if you haven't subscribed to
them do it what are you waiting for all
right guys well subscribe
click that notification bell hit that
like button we'll catch you guys soon